hi dr. Wallach thank you science for
taking my call I'm calling I'm calling
on behalf of my sister we're both
youngevity distributors she was in a car
accident at the end of last year and at
the time they did an MRI and found a
little scoliosis of her spine but they
just did an x-ray last week and saw that
she has a torn rotator cuff and
tendonitis she's 52 five six and 183
pounds and we wanted to know what you
would recommend to help her body heal
itself better okay so she had trauma a
couple of months ago and he has a
rotator cuff problem torn tendons and
ligaments that sort of stuff she got
scoliosis kind of an ass curve of the
spine and she weighs 182 pounds 83
pounds certainly good yes engineering
okay Charmaine what would you do for
Sandra's sister after all those issues I
would get around to healthy bone and
joint packs and I'd also get one of
those inversion tables and start working
on that and also vitamin d3 mm-hmm and
what else would you get from our free
life division MSM MSM you get an 8 plus
plus plus here exactly so charge exactly
right here Sondra
your sister needs to get to the healthy
bone and joint packs and again this is
to support and promote maintenance
repair of bone itself cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue just
between a vertebrae the inversion table
is just genius or she can do that ten
minutes three to four times a day don't
go from horizontal to vertical in one
day you want to kind of work up to that
over a couple of weeks we've had people
gain five inches or so the seven they
may have lost because of scoliosis and
over a period of six months and you have
to see on these 90 essential nutrients
forever right don't forget Charla so
said the vitamin d3 three of those twice
is 8 mm MSM which is particularly good
for the connective tissue stuff okay and
tendons and ligaments in the and the
rotator cuff with the labrum which is
the cartilage circle that goes on the
ball on the head of the humerus the
shoulder okay so she would need three of
those twice a day of
MSM that's two bottles a month what
would you do for pain for Sandra's
sister because she's going to have a lot
of pain in his shoulder and her back and
what you do for her well see I'm cream
and listen from oil in up yeah and of
course there's Sam cream and the two
healthy Baynard heart attacks and what
she needs is the trauma welcomed our
enrollment therapy although they should
put five drops the CM cream and every
teaspoon of the trauma or zoom above the
CM cream mix it up real good with a
toothpick or straw and then apply that
lavishly to all the joints or tendons or
ligaments that hurt and you can expect
within a couple of weeks to see some
real benefits certainly within 60-90
days you're gonna see some real benefits
of the body with the Roman she loves to
rebuild itself